have talks basically spinning everything
in the physical sciences that I could
find and with Josh and dick that require
real-time interaction things like fusion
plasmas high-energy physics light source
experiments a lot on astrophysics today
and at the end of the week and then we
also have people talking about weather
analysis both severe storms like
tornadoes and tsunamis
as well it's a very interesting mixed
audience and so I I know certainly from
the Astronomy side when I've given talks
here before I try to focus it so that
our mathematicians and computer
scientists can understand it I accept a
lot of questions and especially in the
interaction and break time just and I'll
be organizing a couple of panel
discussions and drinks at some point
during the week after the workshop
session ends so we look forward to a fun
and exciting week our first speaker
we've had there was a lot of juggling
this weekend due to flu hitting some of
the speaker's here hard and so our first
speaker has filled in for Mario York who
was originally on the schedule this is
Eric Belem who I have known before he
made his trek up to Washington recently
when he was at Caltech and setting up
ztf he's here to tell us today about
alert streams in the LSST era and it's a
wonderful talk to start off this
workshop because several of the programs
will be addressing the large synoptic
survey telescope and
challenges that we will face and the
great science that can be rewarded with
in just a few years so Eric by all means
take it over Thanks right thank you
Peter and thank you to Peter and Josh
again for the opportunity to speak into
Dylan from Mario who's obviously sends
his regrets that he couldn't join you
I just got felled by illness sort of at
the last moment but I gives me the the
lucky privilege to fill in and I'm sorry
not to be able to join you in person for
what looks like a very interesting
program so I'm starting with Mario's
title here which is all our streams in
the LSST era challenges and
opportunities and taking some of his
ideas and definitely giving them my own
spin so my role I'm a faculty member at
the University of Washington where I'm
the alert production science leave for
LSP data management that's a handful so
let me break it down a little bit so you
know where I'm coming from LSST is a new
telescope that's being built they'll
have much more to say about it later in
the talk but you can see a rendering
here this is a very large sort of
billion-dollar scale facility now in
construction in Chile that's expected to
begin full operations inside of the 2022
time frame and one of the major products
of LSST is an alert stream of things
that are changing the sky and so the
question of what to do with that
real-time stream and how to make use of
it scientifically obviously requires a
great deal of real-time decision-making
and so I think it's a great topic for
this this meeting so my role I lead a
team of research scientists developers
engineers we're building these real-time
pipelines and my job is to make sure
that the product we deliver in just a
few very short years is going to enable
the widest variety of science possible
along the way I'll discuss a little bit
the broader scientific background
I think it's a little bit of a lead-in
to some of the other talks you see on
the schedule later today from from Josh
and Alessandra and Monty who will be
speaking on similar themes and I'll give
a little bit of a preview of things I
think they'll go into much more depth
all so the context here I mean it turns
the next slide the context here are with
Fidel SST but also with many other
cervezas these are wide field optical
surveys of the skies so they're running
and taking images with CCD cameras in
the same sort of bands that we can see
with their eyes and as the night passes
you can see an animation a simulation of
a certain observing strategy the camera
takes pictures that telescope takes
pictures across the sky and one of
several bands and then revisits them so
over time you sort of build up this
stack of images of specific regions of
the sky in different times different
wavelengths of frequencies on you can
use those to learn about the
Astrophysical objects that are there so
the scientific goals here are to find
things that are changing and so I'm
showing here in the background an image
of a very young supernova you can see
overlaid on its host galaxy sort of
appearing and Demming this was a
particularly exciting young supernova
one of them best ever discovered and the
typical technique that's used is known
as image subtraction you can see the
triplet of images in the upper left of
the screen you take this new image and
then subtract from a sort of a stack of
previous images that tell us something
about the static sky that was there
previously and that removes the effect
or the presence of things like the
diffuse host galaxies and in the best
case you see popping out there a nice
clear plain source like Astrophysical
transient and then we can detect those
in that difference image and then decide
what action to take and so in particular
for these sorts of trends
events that appear and disappear in time
the need for real-time follow-up is a
huge motivator because we want to
capture as much physical information as
we can about these sources before they
fade away and so that can span a huge
range of facilities around the world and
in space I'm showing here you know of
course the Keck Observatory which are
you know some of the world's premier
large aperture facilities for follow-up
able to get very detailed spectra and
other sort of measurements of transients
and the upper right is the the Swift
observatory which is a space-based
facility that obtains x-ray gamma-ray
optical UV images and is very adept it's
slewing quickly to new events of course
the VLA for radio and they're also
robotic facilities like was the home
base observatory which has small eye
telescopes that are fully robotic
scheduled around the world and can be
sued rapidly to follow up rare and
interesting events and already today the
state-of-the-art has seen in the
timeline on the left is to sort of
follow up these events on timescales of
just a few hours so this is a timeline
again for a young supernova that was
discovered within a pair of images taken
about an hour apart and once those data
were processed by pipelines that
Peterbilts actually then you see
triggering mainly manually at this point
a variety of follow-up resources
including those shown here on this page
so again the question is how do you go
from that that's those images those RAW
images into the decisions that lead you
to allocate your scarce and limited
follow-up time on these resources that
are highly competitive you know many
other astronomers are wanting to use
these facilities and so the bar to be
able to interrupt the existing programs
and have them salute to your targets is
typically pretty hot so you need a good
strong science case and exciting science
and thankfully we have that in the
demain one thing to watch out for along
the way is that this process is prone to
bugs and gremlins and junk false
positives so on the left you can see a
grid of sort of bad bad subtractions the
image subtraction process is not always
flawless you don't always get that clear
point source that says this is a an
Astrophysical transient sometimes you
get pipeline failures your weird camera
things or optics glints and ghosts and
so one of the challenges that I think is
generally generally solved what we can
always do better is is masking these out
and I think Josh may talk some about
some of the machine learning techniques
that he was really one of the pioneers
in I sort of tagging these sorts of
objects as bogus and just letting the
real Astrophysical transients come
through but as the sort of pile of
needles in the bottom corner suggests
seem once you've got written off of all
the junk there's still a lot of real
astrophysics there as well that we have
to sort of watch out for you know if
you're looking for a needle in a pile of
meals and in other words and so finding
the event that you care about
amidst of all kinds of other real
astrophysics is also challenging so I
told you about supernovae that are you
know one of the obvious target cases but
there are other kinds of exotic
explosions that come through in these
sky surveys things like relativistic
explosions like gamma-ray bursts bursts
where massive stars drive out the ultra
relativistic Jets in recent years
there's been a lot of excitement around
tidal disruption events where a
supermassive black hole at the center of
galaxies tears apart a star as it falls
falls in close to the event horizon and
that also creates a unique optical
signature and then there are very
energetic explosions superluminous
supernova which we're learning more
about year by year and last year of
course there was huge excitement around
the discovery by the Lego and Virgo
interferometers the first
a neutron star merger and so there was a
characteristic sort of chirp as the
those two compact objects spiraled
together a flash of gamma ray seen by
the Fermi optical Fermi gamma-ray
telescope in orbit and then a huge
worldwide effort to identify and
localize a counterpart at longer
wavelengths the optical and radio and so
that was successful a number of surveys
and things ever using galaxy catalogs
the source of that emission and is
already telling us a lot of interesting
things about what happens when you take
two neutron stars and slam them together
of course there are lots of objects in
our solar system they change brightness
but they also move unlike Astrophysical
objects further out there was a lot of
excitement this last actually just a few
months ago the first sort of
interstellar asteroid that there the one
a parabolic orbit from outside our solar
system it has this very unusual long
cigar-shaped appearance and so
identifying we were moving objects like
this they don't have orbits similar to
those we expect is very interesting as
well as the ongoing desire to identify
asteroids with orbits that it would
intersect the earth and could possibly
lead to impacts with the Earth's that
could cause property damage or than a
larger scale extinction events and
finally there are all manner of variable
stars that you know here in these
optical images all the time that are
varying up and down I put a sort of an
amusing example here discovered by the
Kepler space telescope where the you
have a time series of the flux of this
object very well sampled because this is
a space telescope you can see these sort
of weird and unusual dips it's most
likely they're due to due to dust but
there's a range strange shape led to
sort of fanciful ideas about alien mega
structures that might be a coating the
flux of the star I don't think that's
true but it is certainly
example of looking for strange and
unusual things in these large sky
servants so just to be clear I'm going
to talk about LSST today which is sort
of the future of this field but it's
already a very rich field with many
surveys active and I won't go through
this huge London laundry list of
acronyms but just sort of emphasize that
there's been in the last decades a
growing number of these surveys driven
by the advent of sort of affordable
large format CCD detectors sort of
exploring a wide range of niches and
interesting areas of scientific face
space trying to you know pursue a range
of scientific topics analysis tea is is
in some ways really the the most
powerful of all of these and so for that
reason it's particularly interesting as
we as we think about how to make
real-time decisions so today these these
surveys sort of use a variety of
techniques to identify and disseminate
the targets they identify starting at
the most basic level from sort of
private databases and scripts that are
shared by small collaborations then
maybe some events are posted on public
web pages are sent on sort of manually
compose circulars through email or the
facilities like the strongman's diagram
and then there are sort of more
programmatic interfaces that sort of
take input into databases or or share
things through a network like the
transient main server or the vo event
network I will describe these in detail
but just to sort of emphasize that
there's a little bit of a continuum here
between sort of a manual science
specific sort of approach to handling
targets towards more automated general
purpose approaches but even I think in
in the most automated examples that
exist today there still tends to be a
specialization on these surveys to the
specific science that they're best at
and so one of the ways that L assess he
differs is that it's really trying to be
all things to all people
so Alice's T it is in development
and one of the major selling points and
the most relevant for this particular
conference is it's going to produce an
alert stream that is of much greater
scale in terms of number and volume but
also of sort of scientific generality
than the surveys that exist today so
it's it's really trying to not foreclose
on any science case but to enable as
many many investigations as possible so
the the image here it shows obviously a
rendering of the telescope enclosure
once it's completed its development and
some key parameters you see here it's an
eight point four meter telescope that's
that's quite large the the largest
telescopes that exist today have sort of
ten meter scale diameter mirrors so this
is a large facility it's going to
conduct a ten year survey a decade
imaging the southern sky every three
days and produce about 10 million alerts
per night which is a very large number
and so it's going to take these time
series photometry of about 40 million
objects and put them into a database or
later for later study and so I see a
little bit of the development progress
we expect first light sort of late 2020
and then transitioned operations in 2022
so this is located down in on a
mountaintop in Chile here's some other
no other telescope assets and so it's
really looking at the southern sky you
can see the initial demolition to level
that the mountain top site and
construction began so this is what the
mountaintop looked like at the beginning
construction and this is what it looked
like a couple weeks ago so you can see
the facility is already largely enclosed
and I don't didn't have a better image
but I have seen that they are now
building the dome support piers so by
the end of the year the dome should be
fully enclosed was as well in the
telescope what we starting to move in so
this this many of us in astronomy have
been hearing about and seeing that
rendering of Ellis's tea for a deck
more now but we're getting close to the
point where it's actually a real survey
not very exciting
so else's TV it's a telescope of course
with a large ccd camera but
fundamentally its scientific product is
database all of that data and the images
and the catalogs becomes available to
data rights holders in the United States
and Chile as well as various
international contributors the alerts
themselves from the alert stream until
described in more detail are immediately
world public with no proprietary period
and so that's one of the more exciting
more exciting products available and
there's no there's no science being done
by those as those of us who are built
building the telescope and the data
system it's all going to be done by the
international scientific power the data
flow analysis T again is down in Chile
we're gonna send the images up over
fiber links and they will be processed
at the l-cysteine data facility at NCSA
University of Illinois which will also
host Vita Access Center for the US and
Chile and international collaborators to
come and work with the data there's also
a satellite processing center in France
and then the L assisting project is
headquartered in Tucson
there are also satellite institutions
like the University of Washington
contributing to the construction project
so there's sort of three main processing
modes for LSST data
I'll talk today most about the sort of
the prompt channel which is this work
stream of 10 million alerts per night I
that we take and process those images in
60 seconds after the shutter closes we
send those alerts out to the world
for decision making and follow-up that
also includes the real-time processing
of moving objects are in conjunction
with my Met Center to tell us more about
the population of solar system objects
so I again that the
the headline number here is 10 million
alerts per night those require filtering
in order to make sense of so LLC hosts a
basic filtering service it will take
individual alert packets and say yes or
no I want these right don't but will
also send them on to community event
brokers that will do more sophisticated
analysis and classification I'll talk a
little bit more about the role of those
community workers later in the talk on
the alerts are rich and so they have
appropriate IDs for reaching back into
the database what follows a variety of
time-series information and cut out
images like you saw from in that initial
few slides the idea here is that I well
doesn't have the entirety of the
information that LSST has without the
object it has enough that I it can be a
standalone piece of a set of information
to enable that that real-time analysis
so the timeline how this how it works
computationally we take that we take two
images of one field back-to-back to
allow us to reject cosmic rays and other
artifacts and so we take that first
image and while it's while it's begun
and it's exposing and we started loading
in our data processing chain predictions
about where the known solar system
objects are as well as loading other
templates and catalogs we need we read
it out on transmit it it gets compressed
and uncompressed and then the second
image is happening at the telescope
while we and on that when the second
engine is the Riyadh has completed that
starts our 60 second clock the deadline
we have to do all the processing of both
images and produce the final so again we
compress and decompress that second
image do the basic image processing on
the image itself associated with known
previous previous detections in parallel
there's some quality assurance we
produce those alert packets and then
as this is happening on this on this
computational chain we've already
started the other the next visit with
the telescope and so that second visit
is then going to be processed on a
second parallel computer processing
chain and we'll swap back and forth
through the night in order to keep up
with the data flow and so it continues
the second data processing mode is a
little more leisurely this is called
beta release processing it's generally
an annual process where we reproduce
from scratch all of the data that's been
taken from the beginning of the survey
and the point is to do the best possible
measurements on all of these sources and
so we've played different algorithms
that are somewhat more complex and
really take the time to do it right so
again those are those are annual
typically and then the goal is to
produce the sort of a uniform processing
of extremely well calibrated images and
again it's we're reprocessing everything
they can provide a survey so this is you
know tens of millions of objects and
trillions of observations over the
course of the full survey these are very
sophisticated measurements that are
being performed I will do detailed
models of moving point sources as well
as parametric models of galaxies which
have more fuzzy blah be extended shapes
they'll also be nonparametric estimates
of the various properties of the sources
colors and variability statistics and so
what I want you to take away from this
is this idea that this is an enormous
catalog with a very rich data space
that's really well-suited for
statistical exploration and and indeed
that's that's really going to be the
only way to find things in it finally
LSST the LSU project can't think of
every possible science investigation
that users might want to do with these
data but there's scale is so large that
we our ties these are generated
processing where we have computing power
available
next to the data in the data center and
so users with data rights can log in and
access and call the same sort of LSST
pipelines that we're using to do the
processing but tweak them or modify them
to do processing that we don't
necessarily perform ourselves and so we
expect this to be a very powerful way to
perform new and interesting analysis
that's again not not delivered by the
project itself it's a 10-year survey in
six six wide wavelength band passes and
you end up with about 800 visits for
each pointing the main survey takes
about a sort of 85 90 percent of the
observing time surveys a that broad sort
of middle region you can see about
18,000 squared degrees at the sky and
then there are some special programs
that do a sort of science driven
Cadence's that are a little different
then and then are conducted by the main
survey so very very briefly I won't go
into detail here because as a general
audience I want to describe sort of the
software pipelines and processing
pipelines that produce the produce the
alert stream this is the software that
our our team is building here at u-dub
and so there's a serious ax sort of a
big flow chart here showing how you take
those images from the telescope and then
produce alerts out the other side and so
we begin sort of processing the single
frames removing the signatures of the
instrument in the CCD images we do that
image differencing process to generate
alerts to find things that have changed
and then we distribute those more
broadly to the world so that that single
frame processing take out so you see the
artifacts we measure the PSF and the
background and then calibrate so we know
exactly how bright the sources are
exactly where they are located on the
sky I generate lots of catalogs as well
as a fair amount of metadata the image
differencing process then takes stored
templates that record our previous
observations of a field
sky and subtract them in the new image
and then we we take all the images all
but all the sources that appear it's
sort of a 5 Sigma threshold in that
difference we call those different image
analysis sources via sources and
associate those both with passed
detections on the difference image as
well as the objects that are produced
but yearly processing as well as the
solar system catalog so you have the
best chance of knowing whether this
little blip that's come up in a new
image is something brand new or if it's
an object that we know and then finally
we take those alerts we package them
together with the cutout pushes stamps
as well as variety of other information
sort of do a little bit database dump
for each source and put them into a
serialize them to a to a file
essentially and its youth amount to
write them to the world so that
downstream third party community brokers
can listen and access each one of these
events without needing to reach back
necessarily into the Alice's T databases
so I want to talk a little more
generally our philosophically about sort
of why I think the Ellis's T alert
stream is interesting certainly again it
differs in scale from anything that
exists today it's orders a might larger
than the number of alerts that have been
seen from existing time domain surveys
but it's also quite different and
approach from from astronomical
databases that exist so in particular
the fact that it's a streaming interface
rather than a batch query to a central
database I think is very interesting so
that means it's very naturally
real-time and low latency and it also
tends to be decentralized so once we
send these packets out to many places
the things that happen in the processing
in each in point I sort of don't
necessarily have to talk to each other
it's very decentralize and so that gives
sort of investigators the opportunity to
do what they want without needing to
sort of contend for centralized
resources
the other thing that's different than
many astronomic surveys to date is that
Elsa's team made a policy early on that
all of the all of the things that show
up in the image subtraction were going
to be streamed out as alerts so I would
suggest that first of all that suggest
the name of alert may be a bit of a
misnomer because alerts sort of implies
to our minds this is exciting this is
important this is new and so over the
last decade there have been lots of sort
of astronomers wringing their hands that
oh my gosh there's 10 million alerts at
night you can't handle that what can we
do with all of these things that are so
important but the fact is and I think
I'm allowed to say this not all of those
things are important you know they're
they're just they're just new data
points they're not necessarily urgent
you know they'll be an alert for a
variable star that just bounces up and
down at the same period for 10 years and
will send an alert on the first day of
the survey and will send another alert
with its new photometry on the last day
of the survey and so it's not really
that these are all urgent events that
need attention but it's more that we
sort of turned the database inside out
and or sending everything out to the
community the advantage here is that
we're not sort of prejudging the science
interesting we're not saying that we're
only interested in supernovae beings who
are only going to send out things that
look like supernovae and so if it turns
out that else this do you discover some
really interesting science about you
know variable stars of some kind people
will be able to write filters and
classify them and do do that sort of
analysis without any permission without
any changes from the LSST project again
that's enabled because the packets
themselves are very rich the data in
them is world public and so there's lots
of information for classification
algorithms to run and to generate the
sorts of inference that data support so
fundamentally again the way that users
are going to find events they care about
and decide to take action is through
sort of classification or filtering
systems now these may be sort of
community brokers we call them which are
interested large classification engines
that take in the LSST stream and
value to it but it can also be the
simple Alice's T filtering service that
all describes shortly so again the the
challenge here is to take this alert
stream and winnow it down to the things
that we care about and because it's real
time to focus on the sorts of objects
that benefit from that real-time nature
where again you want to trigger some
sort some sort of follow-up and make use
of that real time information because if
it's not real time you might as well
wait a year and use use the data release
data which will be higher precision and
you know has the benefit of you have all
the data inside I just I've talked a
little about this a little bit but I
just want to talk a little bit more
about what information is in that alert
packet and why we think that enables all
that downstream analysis obviously
there's some some identification but
there's also the object records for the
source that triggered the alert so that
that access in the difference image as
well as the object history of that of
that event going back for twelve months
and so it's also linked into the yearly
processing so if there's some
information from the more precise
careful and in processing that will be
useful that will also be available and
then there are image cutouts for just
for examination but also potentially for
were doing the sorts of real bogus
analysis that that sometimes helps rule
out false positives so it's kind of
astounding the number of measurements
we're going to cram into these packets
just tons of different flux and shape
measurements on the image itself various
kinds of likelihood and probability and
then those light curves and time series
statistics so you don't have to compute
yourself whether this object has been
periodic in the last year I will already
be there so it's really kind of a
batteries included data packet and I
think will help kick-start a wide
variety of analysis so I want to talk a
little bit about the the technology in
the ecosystem where we're examining for
sending these alerts out so in the
bottom left corner is that sort of
catalog of differents image sources it
gets stored in at an analysis T database
and then put into other packets and then
we queue them up to send them out and so
the full streams go to these community
brokers that will do a variety of
cataloging and cross matching and
classification and so some users will
want to interface with those directly
and then some will use sort of filters
that they upload to the LSST system to
select just a subset of events that they
care about and so we're prototyping some
technologies that are used in industry
to do this sort of handling of this
alert stream I should emphasize that
this work is led by Maria Patterson
whose research scientists here at u-dub
so we're looking at a number of sort of
Apache Pesci codes that are open sourced
and what you use widely in the web
industry for lured transport
serialization and also filtering so walk
through these one by one that the first
step of course is to move move the alert
packets around for that we're looking at
Apache Kafka which is a distributed
scalable sort of distributed log we're
looking at Apache Avro for serialization
to compact binary format that is
strongly typed and so that's nested can
be challenging to get your data in
because you better get the text right
but once once the packets are encoded
they're impossible to decode incorrectly
and we like Apache spark for filtering
in particular because it has a nice
symmetry between stream analysis and
batch processing of archival alerts so
just walking through these one by one
again Apache Kafka is a distributed log
so each each alert comes in and sort of
appended to the log and the nice thing
here is that when someone wants to
listen or read this this log
keeps track of where each consumer has
with the last alert they have seen and
so it has an advantage over a sort of
the current vo event transport protocol
that you can connect and disconnect and
replay the stream as needed without
needing to be listening listen all the
time there's also a little less per
event traffic back and forth to be able
to the stream so again this is naturally
naturally scaled by adding more
computers
I was developed at LinkedIn and is
widely used industry and has connectors
in a variety of programming languages
Apache Oberoi again is a fairly
structured data format in comparison to
for example XML or especially things
like CSV files so it enforces strict
datatypes schema that allows that to
evolve and so you can throw out
throughout field you don't care about
care about it plays nicely with Kafka
and we've had pretty good luck with it
so far then finally we're looking for
that sort of filtering process for the
LSST filtering service at Apache spark
which is sort of a jack-of-all-trades
general-purpose cluster computing
framework that plays nicely with the
Kafka stream but it also enables
connections to databases and and another
interfaces so I want to talk now a
little bit about the role of these
community brokers which I've alluded to
and emphasize that that they play a very
important role in enabling
decision-making on Alice's to your
extreme so we're sitting the plan is to
send the full alert stream to some
finite number of these third party
brokers maybe of order five you know
plus or minus several and they're
they're allowed to do some things that
the LSST project isn't our or has has
ruled out most notably they can do cross
matching with catalogs from other wait
alert streams so while the LSST data
will provide a lot of information in
those rich alert packets you can learn a
lot about Astrophysical sources by cross
matching to multi-wavelength sources
radio x-ray UV ultraviolet and so on as
well as as well as sort of catalogs of
Astrophysical sources that have been
spectroscopically classified for
instance and so by being able to do that
cross match it will enable a much more
secure classification of the events now
classification process is also something
that elses tea will not do so we will
never survey this alert is a supernova
and never say this flirt is an hour
ilaria variable star will give
parameters that may make that pretty
obvious but they're just
characterization and so the role of
assigning probabilistic classifications
in particular is left or not to the
community so other things that brokers
could do obviously just redistributing
those world public comment packets to
get over some of the bandwidth
limitations coming out of the pollicis
tea facility there's a little bit of a
fan-out effect that we hope will be
produced they can do filtering I hope
they'll provide some useful user
interfaces and then there's a whole sort
of challenge of coordinating community
interaction between follow-up and
collaboration I think there are
prototypes and existing sort of features
that exist today in the world of how you
manage you know large international
collaborations who want to find
interesting events together and then
pool resources like Carlo of telescope
time to get the most signs out of them
community workers obviously can do
storage and archiving and there's all
kinds of interesting questions around
how you handle annotating the
information we learn about these alerts
and share it and that's sort of an
enable citation and discovery so there's
a there's a whole rich rich range of
opportunity here
for these community workers should
emphasize is one of the challenges is
they're not funded by the Ellis's to
project there is unfortunately no budget
line that they can tap into directly
from LSST
even though they're so fundamental to
the science and so managing that process
I think is one that the US community the
world community actually I think is
still grappling what we expect again a
finite number of those community members
to be chosen to receive the full Alice's
Taylor stream and that's largely due to
bandwidth limitations to be able to send
out those tillman 10-million alerts
promptly but also just I just sort of
managed the human resources necessary to
send that so we envision a proposal
process by which this community brokers
will be selected in a couple of years in
the LSST
project itself will provide a simple
mini broker system that's a lot you know
simpler in particular the filters that
users will be able to upload will only
act on single other packets they won't
be doing sort of cross matching or some
points and these more sophisticated
operations and they'll be limitations on
the number of alerts they can process
for each image as well as the computing
time that follows but I think it will
still prove to be a fairly useful
facility for a range of science goals or
that you can express in just very basic
sort of cuts or filters so here's an
example of how you could could do a
young transient filter with just a set
of simple yes/no questions you know you
send in the full screen you ask if the
the point source is consistent with
being Astrophysical or if it looks like
some kind of image subtraction jump then
you look at at the template image and
ask if there's a client counterpart that
is stellar if it is then you're probably
looking at a variable star or maybe
these are you throw those away then you
demand to detections
from that light curve that are separated
by more than about 30 minutes and that
throws away all of the moving objects
potentially from our solar system and
then
gives you a fair number of transients
potentially but then you asked if there
was an upper limit at last night and if
there was then you have a much smaller
stream of just filter young transients
that's that's exciting because then you
could potentially trick or follow up on
those and so the nice thing about some
of the technologies were exploring is
that there's symmetric you put it in a
stream you do the filtering and you get
the stream out the other side and we
think having that same interface on both
ends is potentially very powerful I want
to talk briefly about another facility
called his wiki transient facility which
I was involved in a health tech and I
think you'll hear more about c'mon see
later today this is a new camera that's
very different that provides an
opportunity to prototype some of these
ideas sort of right now so this this is
an image of the large ccd camera it has
a very wide field of view we had first
sighted in October and the server base
starting basically next week and we're
planning an LST like screen alert screen
from this from this camera that will be
again public later this year were
actually have forked many of the LSST
tools the kafka and sort of systems to
try to deploy those and understand a
little better how they how they function
in practice so it provides a way to test
some of these ideas right away I should
emphasize that these are very different
very different surveys very different
telescopes ztf lives on this historic
Schmidt telescope at Palomar Observatory
you can see the pencil drawn and
rendering from the 1940s when it was
built but it's nevertheless still very
powerful facility today even though LSST
is state of the art and being being
fabricated and how so what makes it
useful
Alerts we expect from ztf nightly is
about a millions of about a factor of 10
less than analysis T and again it's
being going into survey mode now and so
we'll have several years of ztf alerts
to test on before the LSS
decommissioning and operations periods
begin so we hope this will be a useful
way to seed some of these technologies
some of these ideas about you know rich
alert packets and big alert strings to
begin so I wanted to sort of come to a
close by looking again at Mario's title
which was talking about opportunities
and challenges of the LSST alert stream
and so in terms of opportunities I think
obviously most most notably is you know
LSST
as a state-of-the-art brand-new
billion-dollar facility is extremely
powerful I think the data should be
reduced as well as any optical data has
ever been reduced and so I think it
provides huge discovery space there's
there's you know huge amounts of science
that can be and can be done with this
this data I think the outward stream
idea and these rich data products will
enable a sort of a wide range of
inference there's no sort of prejudgment
of the science that can be done it's
really batteries included and this alert
stream concept I think is very
interesting because it's naturally
distributed you can bring your own
computing and you can apply your ideas
without without necessarily any any
interference or any permission the
challenge of course is that that's a lot
of data and you know the large volumes
and large event rates I think are going
to be a little bit of a strain and it's
not quite as simple as just downloading
something to your laptop and running in
so it's gonna require an increase in the
computational sophistication of the
worldwide community the others this
decadence because of the size of the
field of you that's large with its but
it's not enormous and so for many sorts
of events like supernova the sampling
that you get from Alice's tea sort of by
default is not quite as good as you'd
like
and so being able to actually perform in
France decide and classify different
event types based on that sparse
sampling I think is an ongoing challenge
there are also a faint targets because
it's a bit big telescope and so what we
already have limited follow-up resources
to be able to obtain in that follow-up
information that's so necessary to fully
exploit any given an event and so that's
even more challenging when these events
are dim I think that again to make the
most of any given alert you want to be
able to join it with catalogs at other
wavelengths and other alert streams that
functionality is left to the community
brokers that are third parties and not
directed by LSST per se and so it's
really a challenge to the community to
find a way to fund that effort and make
it productive I think that that's a was
an interesting choice by the LSST
project to structure things this way
again
it's the survey is is gonna be useful
for a wide variety of science goals but
I think the flip side of that is that
it's not particularly specialized for
any one science goal and so you know I
think many of us with specific science
aims would say if we could drive the
telescope we could run the data
processing our way we would do it
differently than might be done by sort
of the average of all of those so and
finally I think there's an open question
that that people have thought about in
the past but is still a little bit of an
open question of how do you share
information in this distributed
ecosystem where many people are
processing and adding value to the alert
stream but don't necessarily aren't
necessarily talking to each other so how
do we how do we bring that information
back together and share and share
between these nodes of this analysis
synthesis so to conclude again Alice's T
is producing an alert stream
unprecedented scale very scientific
potential I think it's going to be
extremely powerful and
we're using new technologies to deliver
that alert screen testing them now
should I shouldn't know very soon we're
on the right track
but the big question is whether it you
know we will have the community
ecosystem necessary to make the
real-time decisions to all these events
up and and make the most of that
potential I hope that ztf will provide a
useful prototype later this year so
finally as we think about building these
tools I want to share an idea that found
Maria Patterson has expressed before
which i think is pretty interesting
which is on the language we've talked
about we often talk here about this
alert stream firehose that is so
enormous and it's so powerful it's gonna
blow us away we're not ready for it I
think a question we can ask is maybe we
can reframe that and think about what
can we build that produces not a
firehose that overwhelms us but a cute
community fountain allows everyone to
play and to enjoy these data so I thank
you very much and I'm happy to take your
questions thank you okay I will relay
any questions I do have several of my
own but I'll start anybody in the
audience first has a question prayer
motsi so I guess some people you hinted
on but it'd be nice if you could
elaborate is there any potential in this
in this tap persistent Rob resistant
with feedback the new information back
into the packets so say you would
classify an event can you put that
classification back in the faculty I I
think I did Peter Butler G weren't you
repeat it for him I think she I think
Monty was asking if if the community can
feedback classifications and things you
also see the project yeah that's a say
can it go back into the Kafka stream in
some way right I don't think that that
is is in our plans at the moment I agree
that that's an important question of how
to share that classification information
I don't I don't immediately know that
the L assists you project has a place to
put that because again we're not in the
business of classifying and so even
carrying someone else's classification
is not it's not obviously in our purview
and so I wonder this is a little inside
baseball for the astronomers you know
things like the transient name server
which are aggregating you know
information and classification I wonder
if they're there there's there has to be
an analog like that or or even just that
that that specific service that is
acting sort of outside that because
because Ellis is G is big and important
but it's it won't be the only survey
that that's operating in the 2020s and
sometimes I think that you know adding
else's to it it to that of other surveys
will be just as important so I I think
maybe that information needs to live
outside of Ellis's to proper but if you
think there's a strong advantage to
being able to have that inside inside
the fence as it were let's talk about it
has the notion of kind of follow-up
existing transient so at least at the
protocol level you can in a way that
maintains provenance say I believe that
this is this sort of class and then how
you transmit that and who saves it and
who rebroadcast that is sort of at the
level that that that eric answered but
at least at the protocol level we have
the ability to do it yeah yeah I I I
take Josh this point that the the
existing vo event standard has has that
ability I would ask back to Josh
actually I I don't have a sense of how
widely that's used in the community
today you know I I don't have a sense of
is that regularly you know are people
sending spectroscopic classifications
through the event if not why not
that's will answer that over a copy of
beers I think the short answer is it's a
critical mass question sure that that
whole project got close to but I think
never really achieved it there was sort
of right I hope that ztf and LSST would
by the use of vo event sort of get a
bunch of other communities involved to
use again excellent either question it's
Casey law I'm just interested that you
know the model of certain what you've
described for those feet is trying to
get this data out and it's effectively
sounds to me like a distributed
decision-making process right you're
summarizing data to get it out so that
people can the informed people can make
decisions in a distributed fashion but
what are the things about distributed
computing say is
there are very well established
standards of communication right so kind
of touches on this point so and but
you're developing this it sounds to me
the all-city of developing this search
from scratch at quite the grand scale do
you know of any smaller scale kind of
implementations of a distributed
decision-making process and like the way
the data is communicated that it's not
quite so big and has been you know sort
of galiyev in some way that's a good
question i I don't immediately have
anything that jumps to mind but I would
be happy if there were others in the
audience who who had pointers that's a
very interesting question Katie thanks I
had a couple questions here of the
10-million candidates for night what
fraction of them do you think will be
you know bogus we have we have strong
requirements on that which I am trying
to remember what what strictly they are
I think it's about 10% it's it's it's
extremely we have extremely rigorous
requirements on completeness and purity
and that's a little terrifying to me
because it's my job to deliver that my
next question is who's who's working on
that okay now I know who to blame
yes it's an enemy how our associations
done and are you thinking like yeah
basically when you find a new candidate
and then you want to stream along with
it
previous detections or non detentions
how do you make that Association so
there are several catalogs were
associating to you know the previous so
we have this concept of a this concept
of objects which are coming they're
objects that are they're objects that
are coming from the data release
processing that are sort of associated
holistically they're detected on the
coed and then there's this sort of rich
modeling processing for all the images
for the the transients the objects that
are associated from the data released
specifically those would just report the
three near stars in the three years
galaxies so it's not a we're not saying
that this is definitely this this
difference image source is definitely
connected to any of these objects were
just telling you what what then your
violins are the question about
difference image to difference image is
more interesting because that's really
what what produces the is really what
produces the light curve that all the
time series analysis depends on and I
would say we're still working on exactly
what the algorithm that we'll use there
is there interesting sort of there's
some interesting work in the literature
about sort of doing things like the
Hungarian algorithm where you're taking
basically all of the all of the objects
you have and then all of the new
different image sources and Association
associations together sort of in one go
in order to you know sort of get the
right Association so it's not simply a
nearest neighbor process but we haven't
fully fully implemented or chosen our
methodology at this point we're still
was to testing it okay because one of
the things that I'm wondering about is
what you do when you have a supernova
going off near the core of the galaxy
which is active right and how do you
delineate those two at what level do you
just throw I mean so if you're throwing
out catalogue data rather than imaging
data this this question gets quite
interesting right that's not my question
I would say that there's a there's an
open question of whether we so so with
strictly speaking on the core and
there's no way for LSST to you know to
resolve that's that difference spatially
and then that will be a single object
there's no way there's nothing
can do to distinguish it you know it
would be to the user to decide and
typically that you know okay we have
some some red noise variation and all
the sudden here comes with you know here
comes something that doesn't look like
that anymore
there is the possibility of running sort
of a points or specialized blender on
the difference imaging but but it hasn't
been clearly made a priority that will
definitely implement I think it's no
question okay I'm just wondering when
images like the quality say of the
seeing changes from one image to the
next or from the red to the blue and in
one case you say it's encore and then
then the next alert you can clearly see
it's off court and you know that so it
indicates something to think about still
again yeah there are lots of really
interesting challenges around around
exactly those questions and I'd be happy
to talk to you about these because you
know there's an open question of do you
reassociate you know if suddenly you
have a good seeing image and you can
break things apart do you reassociate
that the past sources or not some of
that you know will come through and the
yearly data release processing that's
that's not much help in ya know in real
time but yeah exactly but this isn't
really a real-time application but we've
always thought about the difference
imaging and alerts around point sources
so new transients or moving objects in
the solar system is armed and restful
than people I can would be interested in
finding blobs that are moving right so
creating for supernovae echoes and dust
those are not point sources is there any
anything within LSST to alert the
community
as impossible things like right the
short answer is is no there is not
anything especially well-suited to light
echoes that are not not point sources I
will say that there are there are some
in addition to the the point source
model will also fit on differents images
both a trailed source model or speaking
sources and a dipole model for you know
if you have two point sources that are
shifted a little bit so those will be
and those measurements will be included
with every alert we detect five Sigma
level point sources so you could
certainly imagine that in some cases you
know those morphologies might allow you
to capture something like light up like
like like light echoes I wouldn't say
that that's the right way to do it and
certainly not the most effective way to
do it and so a situation like that is
where you might look to something like
user-generated processing running your
own algorithms on the data in whatever
man-- most effective question from a non
astronomer but do do these alert by
these other than their constrict time
ordering have any notion of a parent ID
is that does the messaging stream have
any internal structures so that
subsequent alerts are connected to their
parents by by any chain or is any such
connection about objects or other
structures meant to be made by the
downstream analysis processes yeah it's
a great question I think the short
answer is the connection is made through
the object IDs in the packets themselves
rather than be anything about the alert
stream proper another astronomical
question viewing the alert stream is a
sort of a sum of a pending query that's
burping out stuff on the unable on the
underlying database what what do you
expect and that users have access to the
underlying database as well as as
the actual information within the alert
what do you anticipate in terms of
generated queries on the underlying data
from from interesting events or just
just the average event
all right that's a thanks on questions
so there are you know we carry a site
thinning model for the data access
center which I think has something like
of order a hundred hundred users
executing large queries which are
defined as you know running for hours or
days i I think you know these these
models are coming from you know the
experience of the Sloan Digital Sky
Survey which was one of the first that
really sort of had a large publicly
accessible database I think it's a
little bit of a chicken in the egg
problem you know the facility supports
it astronomers will do more queries if
they don't if it if it doesn't and then
they'll get their information elsewhere
but I think you know it's it's difficult
to say how priori what the what the
follow-up query load looks like you know
certainly the the design of the alert
stream for better or for worse is trying
to minimize that that reach back but
there definitely would be cases is you
know for hopefully you know a small
subset of events where you really do
want you know absolutely all the
information in the Alice's T database
and think about high-profile events like
some of the gravitational wave
counterparts you can imagine lots and
lots of users trying to get in at the
same time to understand Alice's Tuesday
all things yeah so you're trying to
upload a lot of the classification to
third parties the community yep but at
the same time you have this strong
requirement for a real bogus or
completeness and not having many focuses
won't that require having a good
classifier to do that a yeah then why
don't you expose the results results
better yeah that's an excellent question
which is you know implicitly how do we
measure our false positive rate without
getting getting some classification
of the tricky problem as I suspect Josh
will tell you more about you know you do
need some Astrophysical ground truth
some of some of that I think we can
bootstrap from known sources known
surveys we also expect to use implanted
fakes fairly heavily for this process
but I think that you know it will be a
little bit of a negotiating process
through the commissioning period to
understand understand that performance
you know may be the right answer is you
know that though they'll probably
ultimately be have to be some
partnership with the community I who
will check our work you know will claim
a certain level of real bogus
performance and I expect others will
we'll take a look at that and see if
we're actually achieving what we
promised I guess my question follows up
how are you going to use the community
brokers or the information that they
produce in order to improve that's a
great question a great question you know
I don't have anything concrete in mind
when one thing that is tricky here again
is that we haven't yet selected the
community brokers and so we don't even
know who sits on the other side of the
table I don't I don't have country plans
in mind but I suspect that this is
something that feedback from users
feedback from community you know as we
transition in operations and see where
see where is we succeed in where we fail
you know you will move from sort of
today's requirements driven construction
into more of a dynamic sort of agile
process that you know community feedback
tells us where where the science
priorities are where where we're falling
short and
and where we can add more I so very
quick but this was the first time I
heard anything mentioned about fakes
I guess one question I have is that
these are key to determining the rates
of any Astrophysical transient I have
you has thought gone into how one is
going to characterize images in the
subtractions on the fakes for purposes
of understanding completeness for
various yes you know different I would
say Astrophysical phenomena
yeah great question Peter you know
obviously I'm very aware of the work
you've done here for PTF we have thought
about it a little bit and we're I'm
trying to understand sort of where the
boundary lies here on you know what's
what's our responsibility and what's you
know what can we provide that as general
purpose and useful within the within the
sort of compute bounds we have you know
we you know I know that does another
sort of surveys have done extremely
extensive you know fake fakes generation
to try to understand efficiencies I
think you know the scale that they have
conducted that is probably out of our
scope just for just for computational
reasons that I do expect that we want to
deliver and we have discussed at a basic
level how we can sort of do the the
general efficiency report the general
efficiency per image and make that
available that you know I think this is
something I'd be happy to talk more
about with you about how we can make
that the most useful yeah on maybe
another tangent to that is it possible
after the fact
to put your own fakes in and do your own
studies with the data or at least a
subset of the data you know as part of
the generic processing where could that
be something that that you know we could
bring our own computers to and just pull
the data and do something like that
absolutely that would be an excellent
case for user-generated processing again
you'll have they'll have access to all
of the source code from the pipeline's
and you know in depending on the scale
you're talking about you know for those
who don't necessarily sit at the
computer facility you know they could do
smaller scale things within the Alice's
T data facility but yes it's absolutely
possible to pull the data and run our
pipelines in you know again that we will
have they generate code and of our own
and so whether you just need more more
numbers of simulations or you want to do
a more careful treatment of you know
whose galaxies or something like that
that would certainly be something you
could do thanks any final questions okay
thank you very much Eric absolutely
thank you for having me
[Applause]